Hey guys,
this is API Miss Germany,
24,
and the web is full of hate,
a much bigger wave full of pride and joy and love
has reached me of course that makes me insanely happy,
but also hate,
envy and racism.
But do you want me to tell you something?
This strengthens my mission so much that my topic could not be more
topical and important right now and that we have to change something here.
I can stand it all.
I moved to Germany when I was 6 years old,
went to school here,
studied.
Today I am a graduate engineer,
architect.
I married a German man,
I am German.
Integration works if we understand where we are,
if we know where we want to go,
and if we never forget where we come from.
Let's show together how diverse Germany is.
I would be happy if you will accompany me on my journey.
You can't fight hate with hate,
you can fight it with love.